welcome back to New rockstars I'm Winnie
van laningham or wrapsody baxi
tricksters they call me in the Forgotten
Realms and the new trailer for Dungeons
and Dragons honor among Thieves just
dropped it looks like we're actually
getting a good d d movie after all these
years today I'm taking you frame by
frame through the honor among Thieves
trailer to point out every D in detail
you might have missed like the previous
trailer this one opens on Neverwinter
located in Northwest faerun this time
approaching the City by land instead of
sea as I said in my last breakdown the
Coliseum next to Castle never is
interesting because it doesn't appear on
any official d d maps in the writer and
director's breakdown of this trailer via
IGN John Francis Daley and Jonathan
Goldstein tell us that some scenes in
Neverwinter were actually filmed on the
old Game of Thrones king Landing set
although the last time we saw King's
Landing it was destroyed by a dragon so
they joked about having to Spruce the
place up according to John and Jonathan
edgen and holga returned to Neverwinter
in order to reunite with someone but
because of their Outcast status in town
they're caught and sentenced to
execution Pogo weighs no time using her
Barbarian strength and brutal writing
techniques to escape the battle guards
she picks up a stone tile from the
ground and absolutely wails on these
dudes with it looks like she has the
tavern brawler feet because our gal is
proficient in wielding improvised
weapons John and Jonathan tell us that
these combat sequences were filmed
similarly to Jackie Chan movies like The
First Strike so that the audience can
really see every single maneuver it's
clear from this clip that while holga
has no problem diving right in whipping
ass edkin is reluctant to get his hands
dirty while she fights off a whole
barrage of armed guards he tries to use
a dull staircase to break the ropes
tying his hands like in the previous
trailer we see a brief shot of the spine
of the world the mountain range that
stretches across feyron next Atkins zank
holga and Simon ride on Horseback
through what I think is the outer rim of
the dread ring located in Neverwinter
Woods the writer and director also
updated us on Daisy head's character's
name she's sophina one of the red
witches of Faye and here she's holding
the big bad MacGuffin of the film my
theory is that this is a dracorn and
that the red Wizards if they are going
to use it not only to call upon an army
of chromatic dragons but all also to
turn those dragons into Undead
dracoliches thing tells us a few moments
later that the red Wizards have already
created an army of the undead and you
know what would take that up a notch a
second Army of draculich's next we see
sauce Tam the Charming charismatic
leader of they and also a necromantic
glitch John Francis Daly said this about
his character Jazz Tam is someone that
will be recognized by by long time
players he's a character who comes from
the lore he's super creepy and he's very
powerful and there's a lot of kind of
mystery about him Edkins does refer to
him as the greatest evil the world has
ever known but we also now know that
each character will be specifically
affected by sastem's Destruction for
their own individual reasons later on in
the trailer we see Edgar with his wife
and daughter outside of a thatched roof
home hinting at a tragic backstory that
will likely end with both of them dead
so we can assume that his trauma will
stem from that after sokina performs
Misty Step at the arena the crowd tries
to flee but are blocked by other red
Wizards if they using wall of force
zanko's full Paladin Trope to give us
some dry Exposition leaving no room for
Simon's humor since the last trailer
dropped we've also learned more valuable
information about Simon's character
according to John and John Simon is a
wild magic sorcerer who comes from a
long line of successful famous Wizards
and Sorcerers AKA Simon is a nepo baby
interestingly this description for
Simon's action figure on Amazon says
that he's a descendant of the great
wizard elementster armor also known as
the stage of shadowdale he's also one of
the most powerful spellcasters in
existence and learned every single
common spell in the Realms he can also
heal himself sense magic auras
shapeshift and has psionic abilities I
believe that the old Mage Simon is seen
with later on in the trailer is
elementster communicating with Simon
with his psionic powers in this scene
Simon is wearing the Helm of Destruction
and when the sage boops it he goes
flying backwards John and John confirmed
in their breakdown that Simon doesn't
start off in the movie is a great
powerful sorcerer he is a wild magic
sorcerer whose spells don't always work
according to plan so my guess is that
this heart to heart with his ancestor
helps him tap into and control his wild
magic when Jay and Jay mentioned that
Simon was a wild magic sorcerer he was
casting a spell on this boat if this
scene connects to that comment he could
be experiencing a wild magic surge that
turns his spell into something else
possibly fog Cloud judging by the
moisture in the air these guys also
mentioned that this movie will explore
different planes of existence so this
could potentially take place in the
astral plane we can see what looks like
an ocean and floating Boulders and
things seem to take bizarre shapes here
the astral plane is a transitive plane
that intersects with the many planes of
existence allowing travel between them
while the plane itself is kind of like
outer space it also has bits of other
planes that get drawn in and Float about
my other guess would be that this is the
Ethereal plane which is another
transitive plane and while it can be
described as a great ocean it's much
more ghostly zank asks his homies to
follow him to the orifice which is
already a gross word it turns out to be
a giant hole in the ground and I think
that this may be the way that the gang
travels to the underdark and eventually
to Grapple stuff flanking the Coliseum
are two statues I think that the one on
the right is Lord nashar alaganda a
former Adventurer owner of Castle never
and ruler of Neverwinter he founded the
aligandor royal family and his bloodline
carried on leading the city for many
years the figure on the left could be
his son Dan aligandor or one of his
bodyguards from the Neverwinter nine do
you get really excited to watch a new
show or movie only to find that it's not
available in your country RR made me
more curious about what's going on in
Bollywood but most of that stuff isn't
available in the US unless you're using
nordvpn with nordvpn I can switch my
virtual location on my device with one
click letting me access streaming
services from over 60 countries at no
extra cost this opens up a smorgasbord
of stuff to watch that I wouldn't
normally be able to without nordvpn
nordvpn is also the fastest VPN out
there so you won't have to sacrifice
speed for the sake of your shows it's
what we use with the new Rockstar's
offices and let me sell you it is fast
for the price of one cup of coffee a
month I get to have premium cyber
security on six devices and gain access
to streaming services from over 60
countries at no extra cost it's also
available on every platform to grab your
exclusive nordvpn deal go to nordvpn
Slash new rockstars to get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus a
bonus gift nordvpn has a 30 day money
back guarantee so you can try nordvpn
completely risk-free just click the link
in the description to get started one of
my favorite parts of this trailer shows
hold his ax getting an upgrade turning
molten just like when your DM levels up
your weapons in actual DND with a little
Homebrew John and John confirmed that
the next scene in the trailer where it
appears that the group is fighting
sophina is actually a couple of
different fights in the movie spliced
together to make the trailer flow so
these fiery meteors that sophina is
flinging from the sky aren't actually
what causes the stone Dragon to come to
life the Caster must have used animate
objects a spell that brings objects to
life turning those objects into a
creature at your command for its
duration the statue itself seems to be a
depiction of a copper Dragon next we see
Revel Zen a prison built on a Cliffside
overlooking the Sea of moving ICE in the
Frozen far region of the north it holds
only the most serious and hardcore of
criminals so you know that whatever
battle takes place here is gonna be
gruesome Forge fitzwilliams is
definitely going to be one sneaky son of
a gun in this film John Francis Daly
tells us although he seems to be on
board with our Band of Thieves in the
beginning it's later revealed that he
has plans and motivations of his own I
also think it's possible that he's the
new Lord of Neverwinter which could be
why he's holding these weird Coliseum
Hunger Games with his prisoners during
one of the many dungeon crawls promised
in this movie we see the gang running
through a maze set up in the arena
damaging displays their beasts and
mimics and even diving into a gelatinous
cube and this fight scene zinc battles
drawless in the underdark surrounded by
duragar priest statues thank you using
the dagger sword that we saw in the last
trailer and drawless uses the cantrip
green flame blade against his opponent
Sofina Misty steps away from the owl
bear who we know is Doric in one of her
wild shape forms funnily enough I
totally called it in my last breakdown
the director Masters are definitely
using the rule cool in this scenario
which they confirmed in their interview
even though Druids technically can't
wild shape into owl Bears or use
Dimension doorway Dora can because doing
something that whips absolute ass is
always way more fun than following the
rules alright here's where I need some
help from my fellow d d nerds I was put
pouring over my monster manual for hours
last night and I couldn't figure out
what this monster is John and Jonathan
referred to it as a black tentacle but
LOL do you know how many d d creatures
have tentacles like a bunch of them now
it could be the spell Everett's black
tentacle but considering that Forge is a
rogue with an arena of monsters at his
disposal I'm leaning more towards it not
being magic if you all know what this
little guy choking out Chris Pine is
supposed to be let me know in the
comments here's the deal with the next
scene so Fina uses a spell that the
directors call magehand but the spell
she performs here seems to be a lot more
in line with bixby's hand spells I think
that they may have pulled inspiration
for this Mage hand from bixby's grasping
hand it forms a hand the size of an ogre
that follows and grabs your Target and
can also be used to shove or block main
Chans are usually used to perform a task
like unlocking a door or moving an
object and cannot be used to attack your
opponent which is why I think that they
Incorporated elements of big beats Simon
uses the transmutation spell
maximilian's Earthen grasp to intercept
the hand saving Dory this spell causes
the Earth to grab and restrain your
target here we see safina's rotting
blackened hand this could be a side
effect of her zombification but it could
also be her gearing up for the spell
finger of death which allows its Caster
to attempt to cause instant death
another version of this spell can also
raise people killed by it from the dead
turning them into zombies as well when
we see sofina's face a moment later
she's all Grody as if she's halfway
through a necromancy ritual to obtain
sastam's ancient power the next shot was
described by the director and writer as
the moment Our Heroes come together and
really showcase their strongest
abilities what's cool to me is that the
way this fight is filmed almost feels
like the characters are taking turns
with the action just like in a real d d
game a round of d d translates to about
six seconds of simultaneous action and
we're likely seeing a take on those
mechanics in this scene on to my other
favorite part of the trailer then merch
out just look at him he's just a big
hungry boy it was clearly eaten hundreds
of past adventurers based on the
skeletons surrounding the team and he's
about to eat one more after he opened
mouth power slides down that hill of
Bones finally zenk tells the crew in the
underdark that the bridge they're about
to cross protected by an ancient trap
that must not be triggered lest they
fall in Parish Simon instantly activates
the mechanism causing the bridge to
Tumble into the lava below which is
definitely a scenario I've seen played
out at my table someone rolls poorly and
triggers a death trap the Paladin gets
all self-serious about it and the party
has to put their heads together to
improvise a new plan I know that they're
traveling to rackelsta but I also think
that they may have once again borrowed
inspiration from another part of d d
lore Mount Houghton now is a volcano in
the Crags mountain range Northeast of
Neverwinter that's dormant in our world
but active in shadowfell producing
constantly flowing rivers of lava our
guys definitely are not in the plane of
Shadows here that's more of a stranger
things upside down scenario but I wonder
if the ever-flowing lava stream that
they have to cross in this movie was
inspired by Mount Hope now's dark spooky
twin there are always new things to
learn with DND lore so let me know if I
missed any Easter eggs in the comments
follow me on Instagram and Twitter
whitneypuppy follow me Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]